Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
So today, we're shooting from the AERA English Magazine's publication.
And today, we're gonna talk about the Maestro Hook.
You guys know this magazine, AERA English?
Oh, it's a great publication with a lot of English educational information.
And at the same time, it's got great entertainment.
It's a great hook to use with a conversation.
There's a lot of hints in here for topics to talk about...
...and getting good English.
So, when you need something to talk about with a foreigner,...
...check out this magazine. Maybe there's something inside.
Alright, today's Maestro Menu.
It's like no other.
Yeah, AERA English is like no other.
It's a great magazine.
He's like no other.
So, next.
It's good entertainment.
It's really fun.
For example,...
Yeah, you should read AERA English.
It's great entertainment.
Alright so, today's Maestro Lines.
When you wanna say something good about something,...
...say, "Have you ever checked out that magazine AERA English?"
"Yeah, there's like no other."
Or "Yeah, this magazine, AERA English, is great entertainment."
Alright so, there's a lot of back issues too.
And of course, Native Maestro's in there so check it out.
And see you next week on Native Maestro.
Bye-bye.